[Music]
I'm happy to be here among my peers
tonight and I got to me it's like
somebody that would be remembered sent
20 years from now mmm what safe to say
no one will forget card to be now
especially Nicki Minaj okay you've
probably heard or even seen the video by
now and eyewitness claims cardd a lunch
that Nicki and even threw a shoe at her
shortly after we talked to them at the
Harper's Bazaar icons events yeah what
you just saw there was the before video
but cardi left the desktop with a huge
welt on her head look at that pair Wow
now cardi B claimed that Nicki Minaj
made comments about her as a mom well
today Nicki defended herself on her
Queen radio show on Apple music so
mortifying and so humiliating to go
through I would never discuss any one
child and it's so sad that for someone
to pin that on me because I'm the bad
guy any way you look at it ladies it's
just bad news yeah I mean goodness
alright let's move on because before
that show the stars turned out to
celebrate Ralph Lauren's fiftieth
anniversary the show which took over New
York Central Park was date night for
Nick and Priyanka and for their official
photo inside the couple totally copied
Prince Harry and Megan's engagement
posts
you'll remember Nick and Priyanka met at
the Met Gala last year when they were
both wearing well forgave a toast
gigi hadid and kaya gerber walked the
runway and in seats and Hathaway jessica
chastain even spielberg everybody in the
room you walk around and they're all
wearing around everybody looks good
Blake Lively came ready to play Blake
told us the reason she was sort of
twinning with and it was a last-minute
outfit change because they sent me one
of my looks from the movie and I was
like I can't wear this it's from the
movie but I should steal it as one of my
costume archives scores I'm secretly
stealing it I love the way she looks all
the time and I tell you what i couldnt
get enough of the images from this event
everyone looked so beautiful right just
a nod to ralph lauren how spectacular he
had been for the past 15 20 that was
just fine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]